- Hi, Mom.
- Hi, Cleo.
Okay, we're ready.
How did you decide
whether or not you wanted
to have kids?
It just started like
a natural flower blooming
in my mind that,
"Okay, maybe children."
I grew up thinking
I would become a mom
because I didn't know
that I could choose not to be.
I am so glad
I don't have children.
I knew I was always
gonna have kids.
I decided to start thinking
seriously about
getting pregnant myself.
I've literally had people
upset at the fact
that I don't want
to have children.
But I'm like, "How does that
affect your life?"
Especially, like,
factoring in everything
that's happening
in the background,
including climate change,
is this the kind of world
that I want to bring
my child into?
This is what we wanted.
This was our goal,
and we're here.
Whatever change you think
your life is gonna have
in a significant way,
multiply it by, like, 99.
Life? Blown up.
Completely gone.
The vast majority
of Americans have kids,
but the number of births
in the US
has been slowly
creeping downward
over the past few decades.
I think I want
to become a parent,
and I'm lucky to be able
to make that decision.
To be honest though,
I still feel like
there's so much
that I don't know.
So my question is
how do I decide
if I really want
to have kids?
( babies laughing )
( theme music playing )
You know, it's really
hard to separate out
my desire to have kids
versus the expectation
to have kids.
And if you don't believe
that there's still
an expectation
of having children,
just turn on a television.
- So, when are the kids coming?
- Ya gonna have a baby!
- You gotta have one now.
- People like pregnant.
Do you want to be
a mother or not?
Do you regret it,
not having children?
There is the stigma
that if you don't have kids,
then you're clearly
not as happy.
A lot of us have real questions
about when and how
and whether
to become parents.
So, I'm gonna get some data,
and why not start
with that big assumption,
that kids make you happier?
Since about the 1960s,
we've had pretty clear evidence
that being a parent
doesn't make you happier
than not having children.
Out of the 20 countries
that we studied,
the United States
had the largest gap,
where parents report
that they're significantly
less happy than non-parents.
How do you ask survey questions
that get at this?
We're not asking people,
"Are you happy you had kids?"
We're asking people,
"Are you happy?",
and just asking them
to rate their own level
of happiness.
Cleo: It's not just
the United States.
We see the happiness gap
in all of these countries, too.
Jennifer:
It's really a parental
happiness deficit.
And it doesn't occur everywhere.
There are a few nation states
where parenthood
actually improves
your average rated happiness,
and some of those countries
have extremely low
fertility rates.
That's telling you that people
who do decide to have children
are unusually attached to kids,
and want kids very badly.
Now, we do have some
LGBT couples in the data,
but they differ in size
across all of these nations,
and some nation states
did not even ask
about the gender
of your partners.
We're just beginning
to understand the dynamics
and whether they're
similar or different from
heterosexual couples.
Does the happiness gap differ
depending on wealth,
race, gender,
or other demographics
within the United States?
It really doesn't.
We thought perhaps
that the gap would be larger
for single parents, and it is.
We thought perhaps the gap
would be larger for mothers
than fathers, and it isn't.
It grows when you take away
the partnership
and the stable employment,
but once you control
for those factors,
it's fairly stable
across race.
How do parents react though,
when you tell them
about this data?
Oh, they hate it.
Some of them don't believe it.
I have to show them the data
from one survey after another
after another.
But if we ask parents,
"Have your children
made you happy?",
they would all say yes.
I would say yes.
Everybody I know
would say yes.
But what their children
have brought into their lives
in many ways is anxiety, stress,
and financial trouble
that they would
not have experienced.
- Did you know about
the happiness gap?
- I did.
What's your take
on how seriously
we should take this data?
I might be a little biased
because I've always
been quite ambivalent
about the idea
of having children,
but I think it's worth
taking very seriously.
There is a huge cultural myth
that kids are going
to bring nothing but joy
to your life,
and I think that leads
a lot of parents going in
with maybe
the wrong expectation.
I gotta say,
I look at this data,
and I think to myself,
"Yikes!"
And then I think,
"I probably still want kids."
- It's such a weird, um...
- Why?
I don't know.
If you think about it,
our species has been around
for 300,000 years.
The ability to control
female reproduction
is about 60 years old.
Cultural and economic
liberation for women
is still in progress.
We are among
the first generations
of life on Earth,
which is the only life
that we know in the universe,
that can choose
not to reproduce.
To me, that's
incredibly exciting.
But the act of making
that decision final?
I still wish I had more time.
That's another part of this
that I feel really
anxious about.
Our biology does not
keep up with our
social progress.
And that makes me so angry.
Can I tell you?
Like, the cosmic injustice
of this, that, like,
just as you're starting
to feel comfortable
in your own skin,
maybe you've started
to build something,
that's when you're slapped
with this decision that,
"Hey, you need to turn your
life upside down right now
or you can't have a family."
I mean,
in the biological sense.
Maybe people with kids
are this, like, crazy club
of, like, unhappy people
that want you to join them.
But that sort of discounts
all the other parts.
I don't think it captures
just, like, the fulfillment
that you receive.
I mean, I just love
every moment.
Like, she opens up
her hands to hold her bottle?
Like, I'm...
Fabiola:
Having a child-- beautiful
thing, beautiful feat.
But I feel like
there's just so much stress
surrounding it,
especially in this country,
and I think that's
the main issue,
of just, like,
I like the way things
are right now.
But with where things are now,
I need to make a hard decision.
I am a single mother
of four daughters.
There isn't anyone else coming
to share that load with you.
But these are the girls,
these are my girls,
where if they saw me tear up,
they would go fix up a sandwich,
and they'd be like,
"Hey, do you want
to eat something?"
I was raised a girl.
The world taught me
that my needs mattered less
than literally
everyone around me.
And so I think
actually the best thing
I can do for my family
is to be happy.
Sometimes that means
when you get in the car
and they're like,
"Oh, can we listen
to my music?"
You say, "No, we're gonna
listen to my podcast."
And they might whine,
but it makes me way happier
and way less resentful
than I'm listening
to "Row Your Boat" for
the 80th time today.
Like...
Woman:
Scooch down towards me.
Ready? All right.
A lot of pressure here.
This is a view of your uterus.
- Cleo: W-where?
- This whole thing here.
Looks kind of long,
like an eggplant or a banana.
For a woman who's
never been pregnant,
it's about the size
of a bottle of nail polish.
- Huh.
- What we do is just
take a look here,
make sure everything
looks pretty normal,
which it does. Okay.
We have plenty
of great pictures.
- Do I get to keep it,
like from a party?
- Like a souvenir.
Wild.
What do you feel like
are the biggest misconceptions
that you hear
about the relationship
between fertility and age?
That you have
all the time in the world.
With time,
fertility does go down.
Cleo:
One of the best ways
to see this
is just the chance
a person has
of getting pregnant
each month.
Doctors call that
fecundability.
Your mid to late-20s
is actually when
you're most fertile.
It's about 15 to 25%.
That can decrease
in the mid-30s
to about 10 to 15%.
And unfortunately,
over about age 42 to 44,
it can be less than 2%.
Cleo:
One reason for this decline
is the number of eggs
that you have goes down
as you age-- egg quantity.
But fertility is also
about egg quality,
or how many
of those remaining eggs
are chromosomally normal.
The vast majority
of early miscarriage
is actually due
to chromosomal errors.
A lot of people tend to think
of children with Down Syndrome
or Turner Syndrome,
but those are the outliers.
Got it.
That makes a lot of sense.
Okay, so, we're gonna do
a little visualization
so that you can show us
for a person who can
bear children,
what percentage of their eggs
are chromosomally normal
on average
as they get older?
So, blue is gonna be
genetically normal eggs
and yellow's gonna be
genetically abnormal.
Okay.
Okay, so this is 28.
This is my age.
You have a really high chance
of making a pregnancy
or embryos with a normal
number of chromosomes.
But as you see,
it's never going to be zero.
So, as you age to 33,
there's a higher chance,
maybe about 30 to 31%
at this point.
But around age 37 to 38,
the chances of having
a pregnancy with chromosomal
abnormalities is almost 50%.
That's a number that's
very shocking to people,
but, you know,
as we advance in age over 42,
the chance gets quite high.
It's now over 80%,
and so this contributes
to why women
in that age group
may have a harder time
getting pregnant
and may, unfortunately,
experience miscarriage
much higher than they were
when they were younger.
Sometimes we're able
to make generalizations
based on your age,
but the only way
to know for sure
is an evaluation
of your own individual
reproductive health.
What do you see
as the most important
disparities to talk about
with respect to access
to fertility care?
Cost is probably
one of the biggest factors.
One cycle of IVF can typically
be about $15 to $20,000.
Cleo:
IVF isn't the only option,
but all of the options
aren't cheap,
and often not covered
by insurance.
Something else is looking
at the differences in outcomes
based on race and ethnicity.
There are studies
that show women of color
are referred to infertility
specialists less frequently,
and that may play
into why they present later
for care or with longer
periods of infertility.
What can we do
to reduce those disparities?
I think the first thing
we have to do
is acknowledge it.
We all have implicit biases
that govern
how we conduct ourselves
and how we react
to different people
and different situations.
The patients that are
visiting fertility clinics
tend to be white, female,
college-educated, and wealthy
because that's who can
afford the treatment.
And so one
of the biggest things
I personally would wish for
is infertility
evaluation and treatment
to be covered by health
insurance universally.
We found out about
a fertility benefit.
We met those requirements
to be able to enroll
and we got started
with our IVF process,
and here we are with this
little one today.
I'm incredibly privileged
in that it cost me literally
$0 to get pregnant
because of the particular
biological realities
of my relationship.
We had sperm, egg, uterus,
between the two of us.
But most transgender people
need some help
with some part of that.
As I got older,
what I learned was that
as a black woman,
I was at even more risk
for complications
and death after childbirth.
And it didn't instill
any confidence in me.
I recently helped my sister
inject herself.
She's freezing her eggs.
That was just
a very powerful moment.
I knew I was gonna have kids.
That was never an issue.
The bigger thing was
what would you do strategically
in order to make sure
you could maximize your career,
which was important for me.
- Good morning.
- Good morning! Welcome.
What are we--
what are we doing here?
So, there's a lot of data
that shows
that the financial impact
of having a child
isn't borne equally
by men and women.
- So we're gonna
visualize that.
- Okay.
- Ready?
- I-I think so.
- I feel very cool.
- We're like cave explorers.
- Let's do it!
- ( Christophe laughs )
This looks so tall.
Cleo: A 2017 report
from the U.S. Census Bureau
shows the impact
of having a child on men
and women's earnings
among married
heterosexual couples.
- Ready, Christophe?
- I'm scared.
The key chart
looks something like this.
The male and female spouse
both start out at zero
the year the baby is born.
It's a way to control
for differences
between men
and women's earnings
so that we see the effects
of having kids more easily.
In the first year
after having a child,
the mother's earnings
take a big hit.
The father's? Not so much.
So, Christophe,
this is year one.
- Jeez. Huge hit.
- Yeah.
The female spouse's earnings
don't actually recover
until the child
is around nine years old.
So, essentially
at year nine,
the mom's salary
has reset to where it was.
Yeah.
- All right, ready?
- Yeah.
- Year 18. Go on up.
- 18!
Look at me climb
the career ladder.
Though her earnings do increase
as the child gets older,
the gap between the two genders
is still there
by the time that kid
is officially an adult.
One huge factor here
is unequal childcare
responsibilities.
According to
the American Time Use Survey,
on an average day,
women spent more than double
the amount of time
providing physical care
to children than men.
Yeah, I mean, so much
of this makes sense,
thinking about
my mom's career.
You know, she took off work
until I was six or seven.
It was great that
she was able to do that,
but it's a hard trade-off
to have to have made.
Yeah.
Christophe, one more thing.
- Yeah? Oh, okay.
- Look down.
- Okay, now we're done.
- Whoo!
- There it is!
- Whee!
- Whew!
- How was that?
You know, managed.
I'm a little sore.
I feel like we could've
printed that chart out,
but it's fine.
I really wanted to know
if there was, like, a good
or a bad time to have kids.
- Like, what's the ideal?
- I really wanted someone
to time it perfectly for me,
you know?
What's interesting
is the data shows
that for couples
who have children
under 25 or over 35,
the female spouse
takes an earnings hit
but actually does catch
back up to the male partner.
- Interesting.
- But for the couples that
have kids between 25 and 35,
the female partner
never catches up.
It seems to sort of show that
there is this core window,
25 to 35, where you are
starting your career,
setting yourself up
for a successful life,
and that's a hard window
to have a kid.
The thing about
that data though
is that it's so wrapped up in
socioeconomics and education....
- Yeah.
- ...that it's really hard
to tell what it means.
- Yeah.
- Over the course
of the last couple days,
I've learned that
the fertility data tells you
that probably
the safer choice to have kids
on the earlier side.
And the career data
implies you might
take less of a hit
if you have kids later,
which is a little frustrating.
This question of
should you have kids or not
is such a completely
different question
professionally for men
than it is for women.
You were prioritizing
being at home
and changed jobs to do that.
- That's true.
- Why was it you
who made that choice
and not Dad?
Well, it wasn't
completely voluntary.
You know, when I went
back to work after Zoey,
I basically was told,
"Okay, you're on
the mommy track now."
I was young and very ambitious
and I just thought
I could do everything
no matter what the environment,
and that turned out
not to be true.
I'm really afraid of that.
Yeah, well, you can suss out
your environment a bit.
There were no women
who were associates
who had babies who
had gone on to make partner.
I should have
learned from that.
I don't think that's fair
to put on yourself.
It really frustrates me
that we position this
as an individual choice.
Like, the other option
is your law firm could
have supported you more.
Yes, um, and they were not
prepared to do that.
You know, nobody that
I've spoken to ever expected
parenting to be easy.
Like, I definitely don't.
But I keep thinking
about this chart
and where
the United States falls,
and I can't help but wonder
if it has to be this hard.
So, my last question
is just what could we do
to make it easier
to be a parent
in the United States?
And one thing that
we could do is make
childcare more affordable.
There's a new report
that just came out that shows
as a percentage
of women's full-time earnings
how much do women have
to pay for childcare
in each of these countries?
So, each stack of coins
represents a woman's
median full-time earnings
in each place.
And we're gonna take out coins
to represent
the amount of her earnings
that she's gonna spend
on childcare.
All right, so I'm not
gonna touch any of these.
But I'm gonna take
one out for Germany.
So, you removed for Germany,
but not for Chile,
the Czech Republic,
or Italy.
Yeah, for the most part,
governments in these countries
provide a lot of support.
- Wow.
- So now we've got
all of these countries.
Let's see what
that looks like.
Five, Korea,
six, Iceland,
seven, Portugal.
By the way, this is,
like, $500 worth of coins.
Yeah. ( laughs )
So, it looks like
for all of these countries,
they are here spending
a quarter of their earnings.
But that is still
a significant chunk of money
to be spending on childcare.
Right? That's a huge chunk,
even in the middle
of this chart.
Finland is already
getting into territory
that looks very different
from Germany,
so I'm scared
to see what happens.
So, the United States
is here,
among a small group of
countries where women spend
more than a third
of their full-time
earnings on childcare.
That is very scary.
- So, this is Australia.
- Whoa.
Let's get rid of all of that.
- Should I do Canada?
- Yeah, 34.
- Boop.
- So there it is.
I'm trying to get
a sense of why
there's so much disparity
across the board.
On this side,
from Germany to Italy,
what is it that countries
on this end are not doing?
Cleo: Denmark, for example,
mandates that parents
can't be charged more
than 25% of the operating
costs of childcare.
- Wow. Okay.
- And the government
covers the rest.
In Korea, they were
very concerned
about falling birth rates,
and so they spend
a lot of money on
supporting parents.
And one of the things
that they do is they
offer cash benefits.
Wow, so it sounds like
parents there are incentivized
to actually have kids.
Yeah. Given that finances
are a really big part
of the decision to have kids
for a lot of people,
it does seem like that decision
would be less burdensome
in a lot of these
other countries
than it would be
for a lot of parents
in the United States.
Yeah.
I've gone through
this whole journey
learning about
parental happiness data
and fertility data
and earnings data,
and having it help me
as I'm making this decision.
The truth is, I'm not
gonna be making this decision
based on statistics.
I'm gonna be making
this decision based on
my own feelings
and my own family
and my own
potential family.
And one of the things that
I've been thinking a lot about
is I really, truly,
over the course of my life,
would love to do
for another person
what you did for me.
And I would love to be
the kind of mom
to somebody
that you were to me.
And I would love to have
the kind of relationship
as an adult
that you and I have now.
And I just
wanted you to know that.
Aww, thank you, Cleo.
That means a lot to me.
And it really is a big part
of my decision-making.
Soledad:
A walk down the street
is torture, very slow,
but also every single thing
suddenly is incredibly
interesting.
There is a bug! Holy cow!
Who knew that bug
had so many legs?
Man:
Whenever you're ready.
Trystan:
I think there are lots of ways
to have kids in your life
in meaningful ways
that aren't being a parent,
and that those ways
are just as valuable,
just as valid, if not more so.
- Can you say "auntie?"
- I always just tell people,
"If you don't really
want to do it, don't.
Do something else."
Lee:
I feel this very deep
calling to my work,
and that's what I've chosen
to dedicate my life to.
I found it already.
I don't need anything else.
Since I don't have children,
I'm able to be there
for my family
in ways that I probably
wouldn't be able to
if I had children,
and I take
a lot of pride in that.
There's so many things
that can give you purpose,
not just being a parent.
What's important to you?
What do you want to accomplish?
What do you want
your life to look like?
Cleo, wave bye-bye to Zoey.
Soledad:
And then go do it.
- How much is the UK?
- Woman: 51.
- Wow. Sorry.
- ( clattering )
Yeah, got it.
This is not a story
about the UK, but, damn.
- I'm gonna get
an ultrasound on camera.
- No.
- Yep.
- That's cool.
- Babies.
- Oh, babies!
- Speaking of children.
- Hello, children!
I didn't deliberately
match the data viz,
but I did in fact do that.